por qué
a
[Música]
el presidente argentino alberto
fernández comenzó su mandato en
diciembre de 2019 y el primer caso de
coronavirus en el país se registró tres
meses después en marzo de 2020 durante
el primer año de la pandemia la
aprobación en general de su gestión
llegó a estar por encima del 50% pero
hoy ya está por debajo del 40 con
niveles de desaprobación superiores al
55 por ciento según datos de diferentes
encuestadores entre los temas que más
preocupan los argentinos además de la
pandemia está la economía que se ha
visto seriamente afectada en estos 12
meses pero hay un dato interesante que
habla sobre todo de cómo se construyen
las percepciones en la sociedad de
acuerdo con una encuesta de abril de la
consultora poliarquía si bien la
aprobación a la gestión de la pandemia
ha ido cayendo desde marzo de 2020 la
evaluación del desempeño de fernández en
este terreno es más alta entre quienes
ya han recibido alguna dosis de la
vacuna contra koi 19 un 54% de los
vacunados contra un 36 por ciento de los
no vacunados
[Música]
en ecuador la pandemia influyó en la
reducción de la credibilidad de la
gestión del actual presidente lenin
moreno a 41 días de que concluya la
administración del actual mandatario la
pandemia golpeó su credibilidad del 63
por ciento con la que se ubicó e inició
su gestión en mayo de 2017 a registrar
una popularidad inferior del 10 por
ciento en la mayoría de las
encuestadoras el gobierno de lerín
morena estuvo marcado por tensiones
económicas políticas y sociales desde el
inicio de su gestión frente a la
herencia del correísmo moreno arrancó
con fragilidad y divisiones políticas en
medio de un viraje del plan de gobierno
con el que ganó las elecciones a quien
se le señaló de su incumplimiento para
atender los intereses empresariales y
acercarse al fondo monetario
internacional con una gestión de la
pandemia en medio de casos de corrupción
lentitud de proceso de vacunación y
protestas sociales el gobierno insiste
en que dejara 20 millones de dosis
contratadas para inocular a el 20 por
ciento de la población pero el nuevo
presidente electo guillermo lasso deberá
cumplir su promesa de campaña de vacunar
a 9 millones de personas en sus primeros
100 días de gobierno para
el país del atasco de los ciudadanos a
la gestión pública ante las expectativas
de un nuevo gobierno desde el 24 de mayo
[Música]
el manejo de la pandemia afecta a la
figura del presidente chileno sebastián
piñera que esta semana registra una de
las cifras más bajas de aprobación de
los últimos meses según un estudio de
cad en que suele ser favorable al
gobierno la aprobación del presidente se
sitúa tan sólo en un 14% y la percepción
pública también afecta a su gabinete que
desciende 5 puntos porcentuales este
gabinete especialmente la figura del
ministro de salud de enrique parís se
había visto favorecido por el proceso de
vacunación masiva iniciada en chile en
febrero que sitúa al país como cabeza de
américa latina y entre los 3 países en
vacunar a mayor velocidad en todo el
mundo sin embargo la situación crítica
de la pandemia que atravesamos en estos
momentos con cifras récord de
contagiados en las últimas semanas
cifras récord de personas ingresadas en
los hospitales que se encuentran
saturados en un 97 por ciento pone
contra las cuerdas al gobierno el
presidente sebastián piñera ha
registrado durante su segundo mandato
algunas de las cifras más bajas de
aprobación que cualquier otro presidente
de la historia reciente de la democracia
del país
[Música]